but in the meantime we are very happy to
be joined by David sacks he's one of the
founders of PayPal he spent the last 25
years as a major figure in the tech
world and has been watching very
carefully what's happening with Elon
Musk after the acquisition of Twitter
David sex thanks so much for coming on
so good to be here yes sir if Apple did
this
it would it seems like it would
effectively destroy Twitter as the force
that it currently is that would be an
abuse of Monopoly power I think everyone
would agree what can be done to stop
that
well yeah I agree with you Tucker that
you know what apple is doing in China is
not that different from what apple is
doing in the U.S they are willing to
engage in censorship on a global basis
on behalf of their true pay masters and
by pay masters I don't mean consumers
Apple has them completely locked up what
I mean is the party in power whether
that's in Beijing or Washington this is
the quid pro quo that maggot Democrats
have made of course by Mega Democrats
I'm referring to Microsoft Apple Google
and Amazon they have the most lucrative
monopolies in history and want to
continue minting money undisturbed and
in exchange for that they will donate
lavishly to the Democratic party and
they're willing to kneecap their
political opponents with censorship if
that's what the partying power requires
you know the traditional libertarian
position on this which I ascribed to for
many years I'll just say it was that you
know the first amount protects Americans
from having their speech hampered by the
government okay but all speech takes
place online at this point we know that
there are direct connections between the
tech companies and the government
currently in power they're censoring
people the direction of of the US
government so really if you censor
Twitter you're eliminating my right to
speak freely as an American which is a
constitutional problem so why can't
someone take action against this
Tucker I think you're right I mean
what's basically happened here is that
the government has found a kind of
loophole in the First Amendment the
first amendment is stated it only
applies to government to Congress but if
the government can basically get big
Tech to do its censorship for it it can
claim that this was done by private
actors the problem is that the town
square has been privatized when content
got digitized it got centralized in the
hands of a few big tech companies and
the problem here though is that these
big tech companies aren't just acting on
their own they're acting uh you know at
the behest of of of the government
Washington and you know whether it's the
bind Administration or various centers
on the Judiciary Committee they suggest
these companies that their monopolies
might be broken up if they don't take
down more content and so big Tech has
gotten the message they want their
monopolies to continue undisturbed they
want to keep minting money and so they
are responding by practicing the
censorship
I got I just gotta finally ask you a
personal question so you've you've been
in this business at the top of this
business you know all your life
effectively I'm sure you've seen
everything in the tech world were you
shocked to learn that Apple was
preventing
non-violent protesters in China from
communicating with each other
it is pretty shocking because the way
that it was done Tucker was they had a
an update it was like 16.1.1 or
something like that and they didn't say
normally what they do is when they do an
update they put in the the release notes
what they're changing and they said in
the release notes they were changing you
know doing bug fixes and so on they
didn't mention they were limiting the
use of this airdrop feature normally
Apple is very proud of their releases
and they're eager to tell consumers what
it is that they're doing but in this
case for some reason they didn't mention
it and you have to wonder why
so dark it's unbelievable and I know
that you come on this show and speak
your mind at some cost yourself given
the world that you live in so I'm
appreciative that you're willing to
David Sachs thank you very much
thanks Tucker subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight